- Hello, everyone, how many of
you here first time in Vegas?
- Okay.
- Wow, and how many of you here
first time in re:Invent?
Amazing, just one advice,
always keep in walking shoes.
Don't wear the heels or anything
because there's a lot
of things to walk here.
Wish you all the best if you're here
for the first time,
and I'm sure you will learn
a lot of things end of the week.
Thank you for coming.
- Yeah, let's get started.
Good morning.
- [Attendee] Good morning.
- That sounds right.
Welcome to MAM334.
And first of all, thank you.
Thank you for attending
our session on how to scale
modernization with the help
of agent TKI capabilities.
I plan to start this
session with three questions
and a little bit of exercise together.
Are you all ready?
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- Okay, let's do it.
Raise your hand if you are working
or worked on one or more
modernization projects.
Okay, that's lots of hands
and that's also tells me
that you are in the right session.
Now raise your hand if you have mandate
to increase AI adoption.
To reduce total cost of ownership,
increase return of investment
for your line of business.
Good, good.
Thanks for sharing that
information with us.
Now raise your both hands if you have a
goal to do more with less, that means.
- [Yogi] God saving.
- Reducing operating cost
or reduced total cost of ownership.
No, keep the hand raised.
Keep the hand raised.
Let's do a little bit
of stretching from here.
From left to right, from right to left.
Let the blood flow.
Take a deep breath.
Now we think we are ready for the session.
My name is Pratip Bagchi
I'm an enterprise solution
architect with AWS.
Today I have with me Lalit Kumar.
Oh, today I have with me Lalit Kumar.
He's an AI solutions architect
with Thomson Reuters and Yogi Barot.
She's a tech lead Microsoft
worklead with AWS.
Three of us, we are going to share
how you can supercharge
your modernization project
with the help of agent TKI capabilities.
Now let's look into our agenda today.
First I'll start with the challenges,
I mean transformation challenges,
what we are hearing from our customers,
what's the voice of the field.
I'll also share what are the motivations
behind these modernization projects.
Then Lalit is going to share
his journey on how he is scaling
modernization goals for
hundreds of application
for his organization.
And finally, Yogi is
going to wrap the session
with best practices and how
you can use AWS services
and capabilities to scale
your modernization goal.
Now let's start with the
transformation challenges.
But before I start talking
about transformation challenges,
I think it makes sense for me
to define the term
application modernization
in the context of today's session.
In the context of today's session,
we'll be talking on
taking your application
and infrastructure to a higher value one.
We'll be focusing on taking
your Legacy .NET framework application
to a .NET core platform
and we'll be doubling
down on three outcomes.
Number one, unlocking innovation
potential for your application.
Number two, reduce take
date of your application.
And number three, reduce
total cost of ownership.
Now come back to the challenges.
The first is the speed.
This process is slow.
This Legacy .NET framework
applications running on windows
are often monolithic and complex in nature
and that makes the modernization process
a challenging endeavor.
The traditional labor
intensive works that works,
but it takes years
before you realize the
true value of the cloud
and unlock the innovation
potential for your application
and its process is sequential.
Your entire team has to
wait for all the step
to be completed before
they can move to the next step.
And that also creates
collaboration challenges
for a large organizations
with a geographically distributed team
that also delays decision
making process as well.
And the last thing is these
applications are built
with old guard technologies.
As we discussed before,
organizations are seeing
increased pressure
to do more with less.
So the customers are
facing scaling challenges,
they're looking for ways
to accelerate their modernization journey.
But what about the motivations?
No one does modernization for the sake
of doing modernization.
I'm going to talk about
two motivation, first,
technology motivation and the
second business motivations.
So when it comes to technology motivation,
the first thing is the performance.
Performance, performance
and performance is the key
differentiator why developers
should focus on upgrading
their application
to .NET core platform.
The garbage collection is way better.
The just in time compiler is way superior.
And according to the case
study published by Microsoft,
it can be 600 times faster
than Legacy .NET framework 4.7.
Second is the supportability
and the security.
They are way superior in
the cross-platform world.
The Legacy .NET framework,
they're still supported,
but the innovations
and the development,
they are far better in
the cross-platform world.
And the third, which
is the biggest reason,
is the cross-platform support.
Your developer can start
working on the Windows PC
as well as they can use Mac OS.
But not only that, you
can take those application
and deploy them to a Linux container
and you can take your
modernization journey further
by deploying them to a Graviton instances
to get a superior price point performance.
And last but not the least, you get
to access the large pool of developers.
These new team members
are getting onboarded to your team.
It is very likely that they are familiar
with the new technologies.
So for all the technology managers,
it is becoming a risky
to run these applications
with the older guard technologies.
Now let's look into
the business motivation
because you as a technology partner has
to work hand in hand with
your business partners
to make this modernization
goal a successful one.
And for business team members,
cost is always a conversation, right?
So you can tell them by
modernizing this application,
you can save up to 40%
of total operating cost.
You can not only eliminate
the costly commercial licenses,
but also you can leverage
lightweight containers
to reduce the storage
as well as compute cost.
You can also get the scale
and the performance of the cloud.
As your customer base is growing,
as your organic revenue
target is actually increasing,
this application has to scale
and you can scale using
lightweight containers
or you can deploy them to
a serverless architecture
by leveraging AWS Lambda.
So what about upgrading
and porting process?
So we started this journey
couple of years back
with Thomson Reuters with the tools
and the capabilities that we had
with us at that point of time.
So the typical process looks like this.
It always starts with
the discovery, isn't it?
So after the discovery is done,
you start analyzing the code
and during the analysis
process you find out
the compatibilities as well
as the incompatibilities
before you start quoting the code.
And then once the
quoting is done, you need
to also validate the code.
Like if you have any unit test cases,
you also need to convert them
to the .NET core platform.
If you do not have,
then you need to write it from scratch
and then you eventually
deploy your application.
And if you find any
post-deployment issue, you go back
to the discovery and the
analysis phase again.
And this entire process is labor intensive
because it's a combination of a manual
and a semi-automated work together.
And because of that,
it's error prone as well.
And for company like Thomson Reuters
who has a geographically distributed team,
they also are facing
collaboration bottleneck.
So they wanted a way
to turbocharge their modernization project
and they also wanted
to establish a synergy
between the application team,
which is their product engineering team
and platform engineering team so
that they can run this project together.
To share their story, let me welcome Lalit
and he is going to share
how he scaled modernization
projects for hundreds
of application within his organization.
Please welcome Lalit.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks Pratip. (clears throat)
Hello everyone.
Thank you for joining today's session.
My name is Lalit, I'm working
with platform engineering enablement team
as an AI solutions architect.
In today's session,
I'm going to share the story
of how Thomson Reuters has
leveraged agent tech AI
to transform the Legacy .NET applications.
At Thomson Reuters, we
have made a bold commitment
to become the world's
leading content driven
AI technology company.
This transformation is most visible
in the tools we deliver
to our customers, like CoCounsel,
our Agentic AI platform
for tax, legal, compliance
and advisory professionals.
Now we are also transforming
internally in how we build,
modernize and scale
the very infrastructure
that powers everything we do.
Behind the scenes,
we are evolving our engineering culture,
accelerating the development cycles
and embedding AI into the way we work.
And there's a reason for this
because to deliver professional
grade technology externally,
we must operate like a modern
tech company internally.
And that's exactly what we are
doing in platform engineering.
Empowering development,
enabling transformation.
Now one of our DR values
is act fast, learn fast,
our principle we put into practice
when we partnered with AWS
as early adopters during the better phase.
Over the next few minutes I'm going
to share our transformation
journey powered by agentic AI.
At Thomson Reuters we are
working across decades
of tech evolution,
monoliths, microservices,
.NET, Java and more.
All of it mission critical.
Now managing this environment takes time
and for every hour our
developers are applying patches,
upgrading libraries,
or managing the infrastructure.
Now that's the time
we are not spending delivering new
value to our customers.
One of our major accomplishments is
that recently we completed 95%
of our migrations into the cloud.
Now this move gave us a cleaner
and more agile foundation
to innovate on it.
It actually gave our teams,
you know, the ability
to spend more time on AI capabilities.
Now, however, we were still carrying
around a lot of Legacy .NET code
and that legacy was slowing us down
and it wasn't just old,
it was competing with innovation.
Our developers were stuck
maintaining unfamiliar legacy
frameworks that couldn't
be replaced overnight.
So we had to modernize,
but we still had
to remain fully operational
and that was retention.
- [Pratip] I see you said like you
have 40% of your workload,
which are .NET, like how many lines
of code you're talking about,
how many application you're talking about?
- Yeah.
So that brings me to this slide.
So let's take a look
at our .NET application landscape.
So currently we are operating
over 400 .NET applications
that are running on Windows servers.
And that results in substantial costs due
to Windows licenses.
Now based on our 2024
cloud consumption report,
we have estimated potential
savings of millions of dollars
by migrating from Windows to Linux,
adopting Graviton servers
and containerization.
Now these applications, they are complex
and they are mission critical
comprising over 500 million
lines of code that keeps
our developers engaged every hour.
Now let's take a look
at an example of a highly complex web
of dependencies between
the various .NET components
and the package dependencies.
Now on a lighter note,
this looks like our walking path
this week at Vegas from our
hotels to different venues.
And this also reminds me of
of my morning path from all way
to Mandalay Bay from the
opposite side of the strip.
But trust me, this is just
a small screenshot of one
of our .NET applications
package dependencies.
Now migrating Legacy .NET application
from the Legacy .NET
framework to .NET core
is not just a version upgrade.
It requires re-architecting
the application to align
with modern frameworks and
the runtime constraints.
And this image, this shows
an intricate layer of,
you know, interconnected dependencies each
with its own compatibility considerations.
Now this is another screenshot
from another .NET application.
You can see the dependency map
between the various microservices
and the package dependencies.
Now manually analyzing
these dependencies is a very
challenging task because
these dependencies are
deeply nested.
Most of these legacy APIs are deprecated
or they just behave
differently in .NET core.
So manually mapping these
dependencies is labor
intensive and it is prone to errors.
So we started exploring AI technologies
to address these challenges
and we ended up choosing
AWS Transform for .NET.
Now you might be wondering
why AWS Transform for .NET
because for us it came
down to three things,
reliability, intelligence, and velocity.
Now as I mentioned about the beta phase,
since that time we have been
like we have progressed
from transforming a single .NET
solution in Visual Studio
to now running transformations at scale
using the web experience.
Now before AWS Transform,
we explored various .NET porting tools
and it took us a lot of time and effort.
Now the project planning
itself used to take a few months
and we faced various hurdles
during the implementation.
However, with AWS Transform,
everything changed.
Now the screenshot
that you see on the screen is a job plan
from the web experience.
The AI agent helps us create
this job plan, you know,
the end-to-end job plan along
with all the background
resources using a simple
chat experience.
The unified web experience
provides a centralized management
and it enables the cross
team collaboration.
I can clearly define the roles
and responsibilities
of the team members who are working
with me on the migration projects.
I can assign them the
appropriate roles like approver
or admin or collaborator, et cetera.
And there's also a work log
that provides a verbose log
with a timestamp for future reference.
And there is a nice dashboard
which provides a complete
transformation summary
that includes important
details like the lines of code,
the number of projects
and the transformation status.
- So I understand that
you used AWS Transform
to transform your code.
Do you have any example
that you can show like
how it looks like before and how it looks
after the transformation?
- Sure.
So what you see on the
screen right now is,
let me show you a couple of scenarios.
So this is scenario number one.
So you see like before the transformation,
it's a Legacy .NET code.
It's a XML based web dot config file.
And what we see here is it is in the code
we are configuring the
authentication settings.
For example, the 30 minutes
timeout XML attribute.
Now let's see what AWS
Transform for .NET did.
Now AWS Transform has
identified the legacy pattern
and it has converted the XML
based web dot config file
into a code based program dot CS file.
And you can also notice
that the functionality remains same.
You can see the same,
you know, the configuration
and the session timeout settings,
but it has explicitly
configured the cookie security.
Now let's look at another scenario.
It's a similar XML based
web dot config file
and here we are setting
the target framework
to the legacy 4.7.2.
Now AWS Transform intelligently
understood the legacy
pattern and here it did
a little bit differently.
What it did was it has split the code
into two different files.
Why?
Because in the legacy pattern
we had everything in just
one file called web dot config,
which is a XML based file.
But here you can see it has moved
the configuration into an
app settings dot JSON file
and it has moved the logic
into a separate file,
which is a code based program dot CS file.
So the functionality remains same,
but it is now more modern
and secure by default code.
So we are modernizing
for various reasons, speed, security,
cost, but for me most
importantly we are modernizing
for customer impact.
Now we are running around
10 .NET modernizations in parallel
and these are like
millions of lines of code,
not just side projects, right?
And AWS Transform as a force multiplier,
it is helping us to move safely
into production without
shutting down or starting over
because company like ours,
we don't get a greenfield reset
and these transformations,
they don't run in isolation.
Now having said that,
let's talk about some challenges.
AI is not doing 100% job for us.
There is still a lot to do.
And that brings me
to this slide about post
transformation challenges.
Now one of the biggest
challenges that we face
with running these
transformations at scale
is maintaining the compatibility
of the C# code
with the external or the
third party dependencies.
Now let me give you an example.
A lot of components have
been developed internally,
which are not written in C#, for example,
some of our graphical components,
they are written in C++ code.
There could be other scenarios like Web
forms or Windows forms.
There could also be unsupported
libraries like Windows
WIN32DLLSs or VB.NET.
So this is why we need human
in the address these challenges.
Now, as I said, being an early adopter,
it gave us an opportunity
to act fast and learn fast
and it also helped our consumers
to do a better planning
to transform their production workloads.
Now these transformations, trust me,
they are never 100% success.
A partially successful transformation
could mean 50%, 70%, or maybe 90%.
So this is exactly why
we work very closely
with the product engineering teams
to ensure end-to-end
successful transformation.
- [Pratip] So I have a question Lalit.
So how did you bridge the gap?
- Right.
So whenever we complete a transformation
and when we are ready to hand it over
to the product engineering teams,
basically AWS Transform commits
the transform code
into a new branch in the GitHub repository
and it creates a new pr.
So what we do is we pull
that transform code locally
and then on id we use
AI assisted tool like Amazon Q Developer
to you know, transform the delta.
So there's always a delta that's remaining
because of the various factors I was just
talking about, right?
And the transformation log that
and the summary that I was
talking about using the web experience,
it acts as a guide for the next set
of transformations, right?
So once we address all these
issues then we are good
to proceed with the next
set of transformations
and help our product engineering teams.
And with that I would like to welcome Yogi
to take us through the deep dive.
- Thanks Lalit.
Good morning everyone.
As Lalit showcased
modern applications with
thousands of dependency,
makes it difficult
to do a traditional manual
transformation approach.
Now with AWS Transform,
we can use an AI powered automation
to address that complex dependency.
So now I'm gonna showcase
how AWS Transform actually works.
Where is that magic coming
and what it is doing to help
customers modernize
this legacy application?
Let's look at the benefits.
So number one benefits
is it help accelerate transformation
of .NET application by
up to four times faster.
Whether it's an analysis
phase or dependency mapping
or you have to do compatibility assessment
or refactoring the code.
All of this times reduce
as what Lalit showcase
for Thomson Reuters use case
from months of plannings
to weeks of execution, right?
So overall you increase
the speed of your migration.
Next is in cost savings, windows license.
How many of you knows about
Windows licensing cost, right?
It cost up to 40% more
than the Linux server as
what Pratip mentioned earlier.
So not only licensing with Windows,
it comes like maintenance, upgrades
end of support challenges.
You can eliminate all of this
and on top of this,
if you can also save
the transformation cost,
let me ask you this question Lalit,
how much did you pay off
for using AWS Transform?
- [Lalit] Absolutely nothing.
- Exactly.
It's free of cost, right?
So you save the cost required
for all this modern transformation tools
that you are using for planning,
for resources, for analysis
and for conversing converters,
remediating for refactoring,
all these things is handled
using AWS Transform.
And third thing is about quality
because you can do manual transformation,
but how do you ensure that your quality
is as best, right?
So we use generative AI LLM, we have a
.NET expertise deeply induced
into this Amazon bedrock
large language models LLMs.
And that does this transformation.
So because of that you
get the best quality
of the ported code, at the same time,
let me ask you these questions.
How many of you have only one application
in production only?
We don't have only one application, right?
We have hundreds of application
and in Thomson Reuters
use case they had 400 such
application in production.
So to modernize this hundreds
of application at scale in parallel,
that's another benefit
of using AWS Transform.
Now let's deep dive into how it works.
It comes with two experience,
one of them is web experience
and I'm looking at the time
to see if I can talk about this.
Okay, let me just wait
for a couple of more minutes
and I will talk more about it.
So with web experience,
the way it's an react based spa front end
where you can port your repository
and then remind me again
what was your repository?
- [Lalit] GitHub.
- GitHub, yeah.
So if you are using GitHub
Bitbucket, GitLab
or Azure DevOps,
you can point your
repository to bad experience.
And once you point your repository
you can select the projects
within the repository
and once that's finalized
you can give an approval
to AWS Transform to start
working on the transformation.
And it uses like 300 different
customized parameters
that you can do to customize
your transformation.
If you have your custom negate
packages that you are using,
you can even upload that
and ask AWS Transform to use that.
So it generates a real time transformation
summary on the dashboard.
And one more important
is if you have multiple projects,
it uses a batch of 50
application in a batch
and it does the transformation
using that batch.
Another thing is if you
have a multiple projects
and multiple teams, so now I think I can,
looking at the time, I think I can say
great news we are releasing
is we are gonna have a multiuser
collaboration including
your partners as well.
So before you can only
have a workspace with a job
that only one person works
or now you can have multiple
teams whether you are an IT
administrator, whether you are a developer
or you are a DBA or a program manager,
you can now collaborate
together on the same AWS
transform workspace.
Not only that, if you
are a partner working
with a modernization with a customer,
then you can also collaborate
on the same workspace.
That's all available
from now 11:00 AM today.
So that's another great exciting features.
It just got released.
That's about web experience.
Next is an IDE experience.
How many of you are a developer?
Lots of developers here.
Yeah, so except for me,
I didn't start my career
as a developer so,
but anyway, if you are a developer,
you are used to with a
Visual Studio, IDE, right?
So we give you the same experience
using Visual Studio IDE so
that you can open your solution file
and port to using AWS
Transform to a newer version.
What you can see here with
the developer experience,
there isn't side by side comparison.
So the intelligent code differential,
it highlights the difference
between the two versions,
the one which is .NET framework,
another which is .NET core.
So now you can see that
what's been changed
so you can easily understand
the transformation.
With IDE version another thing is you can
also generate the documentation
it's gonna point to the .NET documentation
as well so that you can learn it
as you are doing the
transformation as well.
Now, which experience is good?
Which one is bad?
There is no good or bad experience.
It depends on your personality.
So you are, you said you are
developer so you must have start.
Let me ask you this question,
which one you started
for Thomson Reuters use case?
- So we started with the IDE experience
because we started small
and then started scaling out
using the web experience.
- Nice.
So if you are a developer,
if you just want
to do a POC for one application,
you start with an IDE experience.
Or if you are a DevOps personality,
you can start within web experience.
I have seen customers
started with a web experience
and then they want to do
sometimes, you know what,
they don't even know how many applications
are .NET framework
because we have hundreds
of application in the repository.
If you want to just do a
full scan of your repository,
find out how many of them are .NET
framework application,
what does the overall transformation
summary looks like for all the projects.
And you can create a business case,
take it to your management
and showcase that hey,
this is what we have, we got like
so much of cost savings opportunity,
let's modernize them.
So that will help you to make a decision
and then take one application
and go to the IDE version
and try to port it, try
to transform it using IDE
and if there is any failures you can go
back and forth as well.
Now let's see how it works.
So on the left here is
in your .NET application framework
application with a solution file
with multiple projects,
the traditional .NET web config file,
business logic and unit test.
When you feed that into AWS Transform,
it goes into this tri-state
loop, analyze, validate,
analyze, transform, validate,
we call it as a tri-state loop
because it has to do the porting
until it finds the best fit.
So it converts your .NET
framework applications,
web dot config to the program.cas,
the business logic it's been
converted using thousands
of predefined code conversion
patterns that we have.
It goes through that and
it does the conversation.
And in the validated phase
it does the validation as well.
Your unit tests are executed
and one more thing is to
also check for the approval.
There is always human in the loop
because you want to make sure that
before even you get
started, you need a human
to approve the repository.
You need human to approve
how many projects you are selecting
and you need approval
to make sure your transformation
is okay to deploy that.
Now let's see the deep
transformation stages.
The first stage is a discovery stage.
This is where AWS Transforms
determines the number
of line code, what type
of application it is.
Is it a Windows form application,
web form application,
WPF application, MBC application.
What it is in my portfolio,
it identifies the number
of lines of code as well as
what's required for doing
an overall assessment.
The next phase is an analysis phase.
This is where the
dependency mappings happens.
It's whether it's an internal dependency
or an external dependency.
So your solution can depend
on multiple projects in within
or you can have one solution file
depends on other solution in folder
or you can even have external dependency
with another repository.
Everything is identified at this stage.
How many of you are familiar
with nugget packages, right?
AWS Transform supports 250
nugget packages, right?
So it does that third
party library assessment,
identify the DLLs, identify the APIs calls
and do all analysis and generates
and detail assessment
report end of this stage.
And the next stage is a planning phase.
So this stage it does create
an actual transformation
strategic creation.
What's the timeline required?
How many resources are required?
You know, taking the actual PM's job
is done in this
planning phase by AWS Transform
and at the end you get an AWS Transform
to do an administrator approval.
Last phase, the fourth
phase is an execution phase.
So with this phase, actual magic happens,
actual work happens in this phase,
this is where the automatic
code conversation happens.
We have like pre-train thousands
of different .NET
transformation code patterns.
It goes through them until
it finds the best solution.
And at the same time,
if you have any unit tests supplied
with your project, it does execution of
that unit test as well.
And the lastly, the validation phase.
How many of you have
a performance problem in
your .NET application?
Legacy framework application has a
performance problem, right?
So you want to make sure
the ported code also meets
the performance requirement.
At least it's same or better, right?
So with the performance metrics
evaluation before and after,
it makes sure that it it
does an proper checking
before you do the transformation,
then it creates the transformation
assessment summary report
and lastly it creates the
Linux readiness report.
Now let me ask you this question Lalit,
what is your end state goal
for deploying this application
which you modernized?
- [Lalit] Yeah, so we definitely want
to run these on Linux containers.
- Linux containers, right?
So but then how do you know if your
application is Linux ready?
Right?
So AWS Transformation
will give you a Linux
readiness report.
So it makes sure that the
imported code is now ready
to run on Linux
and if it's missing any
gaps it's gonna list
out and it's gonna give you
remediation steps as well.
What you can do to remediate those issues.
So that's all about the transformation.
Now let's talk about
security of this service.
Security is job zero at AWS.
A lot of customer asked
me, I'm from Canada,
so when AWS Transform first started,
it was only available in US east
and Frankfurt region, right?
So customer asked me, "Hey Yogi,
when it is coming in Canada central
like I really want
to use because you know
some government standard they don't
want to send your code
outside your your region," and I'm happy
to announce that today
as of now we started supporting
to six more region AWS Transform
for .NET is gonna be
available in six more region
including Canada Central as well.
So all my Canadian customers can take
an advantage right now.
Now let's look at the
security point of view.
How does this service works right?
So when a user sends
an authenticated users,
again this has to be
identity manager, I am
authenticated user only.
When it goes request to
then AWS Transform it go
through an API gateway
and this first request
itself is TLS 1.3 encrypted.
So this connection is encrypted,
then it goes to API gateway.
This is where AWS web application
firewall handles the red
limit and request filtering.
At the same time,
now when it goes further,
it uses and temporary processing
for doing all this transformation.
So if you are using an IDE experience,
it does the work locally
on your environment
and if you are using a web experience,
what it does, it creates
a temporary EC2 instance
into the VPC.
And this has been destroyed
after the transformation is done.
So it's all data is being purged
and we don't keep this data in forever.
It's like a temporary processing.
And during this all,
if you need to put a temporary storage,
it used an Amazon S3 for storage
and that is being encrypted
with AWS K management service,
AWS Key, KMS.
And now if you said, hey I want
to do my custom keys, can you do that?
Yes, you can also do a
custom key encryption on top
of AWS key management service as well.
Another thing is authentication.
Another great exciting news.
Until now it was only supporting
an IMM authentication in identity center.
But as of today,
now AWS Transform supports Okta as well
as Microsoft Entra ID as
an authentication method.
So now you can also have
a broader collaboration
between different
authentication IDP provider
to use AWS Transform.
Next is an AWS CloudTrail
where all the API
and audit things are getting logged
and we also have Amazon CloudWatch
that you can have your detail monitoring.
Now how many of you have
tried AWS transform before?
Because it released in May of this year.
Yeah.
So when you tried this,
it did not allow you
to continue from the fail job, right?
If you have to redo the stuff.
But again, another good news
today from now on you can
restart your fail job.
You can continue from where it end,
you can collaborate
with multiple teams,
you can collaborate with multiple roles
and you can have like
administrator, contributor
read only this kind of different roles
in within AWS Transform
and it stores everything
into AWS CloudWatch,
which you have access,
before it was still storing
but you did not have access.
But now we make it more transparent.
We listen to your request,
we listen to customer requirement
and make it available
for you so you can understand
what actually it's doing.
So CloudWatch monitoring
will be there for you as well.
Now every customer I
talk about AWS Transform,
they ask me this question, tell me Yogi,
if my application is an Windows
Web Forms, is it supported?
If my application is an MVC application,
my application is WCF application.
Is it supported vault
supported, vault's not
supported, right?
So you can see here the source
.NET version supported if
you have .NET framework 3.5
and up, .NET core 3.1, .NET standard two,
just now we started supporting
that at 11:00 AM as well.
The .NET standard two is also now
supported if you have that.
And what is a destination
is in .NET eight.
So probably Lalit your destination
also .NET eight, right?
Right now?
- [Lalit] Currently, yes.
- But we are happy to announce today
that if you are looking forward,
we can also support your
application on .NET 10 now
because that's the newest long term
supportability version
Microsoft released earlier this month
and we are now supporting
that as a destination as well.
So .NET 10 is also supported.
So, and one of the things
you mentioned in your presentation
as a post transformation limitation
that you had in Web Forms, right?
So those Web Forms now we can have
that converted into Blazor as well.
So you can also maybe plan
that for your future project
to convert those ASP .NET
Web Forms into ASP .NET
Core Blazor as well.
If you have MVC Razor ASP .NET pages,
that can be also converted
into ASP .NET core
and here comes the excitement.
Actually I'm gonna,
before I click on next slide, I just want
to make sure I got the
permission from my, good.
All right, so tell me about
what database you are using Lalit,
for your .NET application.
- Mostly SQL server.
- SQL Server, okay.
So we are happy to announce today
that we will be starting
the Windows full stack
modernization, which
includes your .NET as well
as SQL Server database.
So now if your application has a SQL
and .NET together,
your SQL will be modernized too.
Amazon Aurora for PostgreSQL.
So AWS transfer will help
you do a Windows full stack
end-to-end modernization.
And this is a big news for me
because I've been DBA in my whole life
and I know how difficult
it to convert from SQL Server
to Aurora PostgreSQL
because both of them are different engine,
the schema converses in
itself is challenging,
T-SQL to PL/pgSQL conversion,
transactions cementings are different.
Even the optimizer query tuning
everything works differently.
Indexes, indexes are also working
differently as well as the security.
And trust me, AWS Transform
for Windows full strike
modernization handles
everything in the backend.
So it removes all manual intervention
and it it does the schema conversation
to Amazon Aurora PostgreSQL.
Now you may ask how about my data?
So you can also convert your data
to Amazon Aurora PostgreSQL.
So as first step it converts the schema.
Second step, it does the data migration.
And you will ask me a question, "Hey Yogi,
how about my application?"
It also modernize the application
which has a SQL server
code written within the application.
It converts that as an Amazon
Aurora PostgreSQL code.
So it's a full stack
end-to-end modernization
and we are so proud to announce today
that it's gonna be
available for all of you
to start using in all
the total eight region
that we are supporting AWS Transform.
So that's a big news
you can get hear more in the keynote
tomorrow about that.
More details as well.
And if you want to learn more about it,
we have lot of sessions,
embargo sessions will be available
for you in your catalog as well.
Check out the re:Invent
catalog for this topic
and you can mark that in
your calendar as well.
There are more resources
to learn more about it.
But before I go that stage,
I would like to ask Lalit to say,
can you tell about
what's an overall outcome
of your modernization?
- Sure, happy to talk about it.
So we have come down from you know,
running transformations
for a few months to just a few sprints.
Currently we are
modernizing over 1.5 million
lines of code per month.
And this is possible
because we are working
closely, you know, in synergy
with the product engineering teams
and you know, all the
initial POCs that we did.
It helped a lot to do a proper planning
and ensure, you know, our consumers
to do a complete end-to-end
transformation using
AWS Transform four.net.
So one important thing I
would like to say here is
that it gives our developers
the time to build the future
and not maintain the past.
- That's exactly what you said it.
And since as I understand,
you are still transforming, right?
- We are, yeah.
And it's just the beginning.
- It's something is still running
for in the Thomson Reuters
workspace right now.
They are still transforming the code.
So they have started,
now it's about your turn.
Like what the message that I would like
to give is free of cost.
So identify your simple application
and I want you to understand
and experience yourself.
Try it out firsthand for
your simple application
and see how it looks for you.
If you do more help, do a POC reach out
to your account team
and then maybe reach out to us
and we can help you do the POC
and find out the cost savings
you can get, estimates
the, or do an estimation
and then present the business case
to your management to see
how much it can help you save cost.
And lastly, AWS Transform
will help your modernization
to take to the next level, right?
So instead of running it a slow, steady
and manual modernization,
now you can have a fast
AI based and parallel modernization
for your application.
We have created a case study
working with Thomson Reuters.
So here is an QR code to
link to that case study.
There are more resources for AWS Transform
and we have more sessions
hands-on workshop.
So please check out this QR code
because this has the workshop
for this new Windows
full stack modernization.
If you want to see how it is
like builder session workshop.
And there are also workshop
on using AWS Transform for .NET as well.
So check out all the resources
that you have available.
And you know what, looking at the time,
I'm gonna now ask Lalit a question
before I hand it over
to you guys for question answer.
Can you tell me a best
tips that you have it
for this audience?
- Well, I can think a
couple of them right now.
I think the first one would be start small
and then you can scale out
using the web experience.
So you don't have to worry about,
even if you want to start
with a POC and most importantly be ready
to face some challenges,
there will be failures for sure
because as I said, these transformations,
these are never 100% success.
So you can use AI assisted tools
to transform the delta
and there's always human in the loop.
So that's what I can-
- Thank you very much
for sharing those tips.
And we are here so if you have
any questions we can ask.
We purposely kept this some
time for question answers
because you know,
we know that you might have a lot
of questions about how
about AD .NET support.
It's supported right now.
How about Entity framework support?
It is supported from Entity framework
to Entity framework core.
How about VB .NET?
That's coming up right?
So any other questions
that you might have it,
we are here to help.
So having said that,
we are gonna wrap up this session.
Thank you everyone for joining.
You can ask any question
that you have for us,
we will be here to answer the questions
and please don't forget
to fill out the session survey.
It's very important for us
to get the survey results.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)